RL: Here we see cells flowing through the bloodstream.
But let's focus on this rolling macrophage
that sticks to the endothelial cells that line the blood
vessels by adhering to proteins.
It's almost like molecular velcro.
The surface of the cell is remarkably dynamic,
with membrane proteins that form connections with other cells,
and respond to external signals.
If we flip across the membrane and look on the inside of the cell,
we'll see this remarkable internal architecture, made up
of the cytoskeleton.
It's very similar to the structural elements that's
holding up the ceiling over your head, but unlike those structural elements,
these are very dynamic.
They assemble, and in this case, we're looking
at an acting filament, or several acting filaments assembling,
but they can also disassemble when other proteins sever
those structural elements.
Here we're looking at a microtubule, which is much more complex,
but it too assembles and disassembles in some truly remarkable ways.
These structural elements also serve as highways
that motor proteins use to drag, for example, vesicles.
These vesicles are full of proteins and other macromolecules that
are distributed throughout the cytoplasm of the cell.
Messenger RNAs are transported out of the nucleus,
and serve as templates for protein translation.
So ribosomes assemble on these messenger RNAs,
and as those proteins are made, some of them
are free to float in the cytoplasm, while others bind to other proteins
that help target them to organelles, such as this mitochondrion
that you're seeing right now.
Still other proteins are translated directly
into other organelles like the endoplasmic reticulum.
The endoplasmic reticulum releases vesicles once again,
containing proteins and other macromolecules.
So here we see the Golgi apparatus that's
receiving vesicles and also releasing vesicles, some of which
fuse with the plasma membrane and dump their cargo
into the external environments.
And also release transmembrane proteins into the plasma membrane.
These proteins can change their shape dramatically in response
to external signals.
These changes in shape allow them to bind
to other proteins, which in the case of this macrophage,
causes it to stop rolling, dramatically change shape, and squeeze in
between two neighboring endothelial cells
to go and fight infection in the tissue.